You might have guessed that it's going to be skinnier, because if n increases
from 2 to 5, the denominator of this standard deviation of the distribution is
going to be bigger. Meaning that this standard deviation or this standard error
is going to be smaller, that means that the distribution of sample mean is going
to be skinnier. But it's also great if you use the applet, because that's a
really good visualization tool. Let's do that. So we'll roll five dice, and then
take the average of all the numbers that show up at the top. And then we'll do
this at least 100 times. Let's do it a 1000 times. And you see we have a
skinnier normal distribution. Again let's compare this to if we only rolled two
dice. Then we get a much wider distribution.